♪ ♪ ♪
- Benoit Pinette, alias Tire le
Coyote, merci de nous accueillir
à Saint-Élie-de-Caxton, pour
nous présenter votre cinquième
disque, "Au premier tour
de l'évidence", et il s'ouvre,
cet album-là avec la voix
de Joséphine Bacon.
- ♪ Mes yeux affichent complet ♪
- Est-ce que vous vous êtes
imprégné de la culture
autochtone pour vos nouvelles
chansons?
BENOIT PINETTE, TIRE LE COYOTE
auteur-compositeur-interprète
- Bien en fait, là où ça m'a
inspiré et influencé, c'est...
c'est dans ce rapport-là
à la lenteur, à la nature aussi.
Ce que j'ai retrouvé beaucoup
dans l'environnement
d'enregistrement ici.
Je passe beaucoup de temps
à Saint-Élie-de-Caxton
depuis plusieurs mois et dès que
j'arrive ici, c'est...
c'est automatique, je me sens...
je me dépose.
♪ Si personne s'attarde
à la couleur du vent ♪
Et à ce niveau-là, clclclclair
que je suis très sensible
à la culture autochtone,
à Joséphine entre autres,
qui est... qui est magnifique
dans sa manière de ré
dans sa... son pouvoir
d'évocation finalement.
- Vous me semblez être en paix
comme jamais auparavant.
- Je me sens beaucoup plus...
Oui, c'est peut-être
12 années de thérapie aussi
qui finissent par...
(rires)
Qui fipapapapapar fonctionner!
Non, mais je vais répondre oui
à ça. Je suis... Je suis assezdt
puis, t'sais, c'est ça, hein!
Le danger, c'est de voir
le bonheur comme une destination
alors que ouououououour moi,
c'est un long chemin puis...
puis qui se veut ancré dans
l'acceptation et la patience.
Puis c'est ce que je pense
que je réussis plus à faire qu'à
l'époq'a'a'a'a'a'avais une espèe
de violence ou d'agressivité
intérieure.
♪ Et tu deviens l'écorce
sur mes failles invisibles ♪
- Sur votre nouvel album,
vous avez une chanson écrite
en collaboration avec l'écrivaiz
que vous êtes toujours,
comme Robert Lalonde,
à la recherche de la beauté
rsrsrsrsrsrsrs la douleur.
- Bien c'est pas difficile
de ressentir de la douleur pour
moi, de ressentir une espèce
d'anxiétotototototototidien.
J'ai juste à ouvrir le journal,
à regarder les nouvelles,
à regarder certaines
manifestations pui
automatiquement dépassé.
Ma confiance en l'humanité
prend le bord.ntntntntntntntre,.
j'ai ce besoin constant
de chercher la lumière et
l'espoir dans tout ce que
je vois d'un peu négatif,
t'sais.
Puis l'oeuvre de Robert,
c'est ce qu'elle me fait.
J'ai l'impression, quand j'ai
plongé dans cette oeuvre-là,
particulièrement dans
ses carnets, j'ai ressenti
cette espèce de passé trouble,
agencé à une volonté de voir
la beauté du monde, d'observer.
- Dans votre premier recueil de
poésie intitulé "La mémoire est
une corde de bois d'allumage",
vous parlez de l'enfance,
des ers s s s s s s s s répéter.
Dans quelle mesure vous avez
voulu faire la paix
avec votre propre enfance?
- e e e e e e e e e en creusant
un peu, puis sur l'aspect
héréditaire des choses, que
ces blessures-là se perpétuent
depuis des générations
Ce que j'ai pu reprocher à mes
proches, ils les ont reprochés
à ses parents qui l'avaient
probablement reproché à
leurs parents. P
moment où, à travers l'écriture
de ce recueil-là, je me suis
dit : oui, mais c'est où qu'une
chaîne comme celle-là s'arrête?
Puis sans me prendre pour un
superhéros, à travers l'écriture
de ça, je me suis dit :
OK, j'ai envie de briser
cette chaîne-là puis de juste
entrevoir un peu d'espoir dans
tout ça puis de léguer quelque
chose de positif et de lumineux
à mes propres enfants.
♪ Le ciel est back order ♪
- Je veux revenir
sur votre album "Désherbage",
2017, album qui a changé
votre carrière du tout au tout.
Lorsqu'on crée une chanson
comme "Le ciel est back order",
comment on vit avec ça
pour essayer de la surpasser
ou d'atteindre un tel niveau
de poésie?
- On n'y pense pas.
Pour moi, "Le ciel est back
order", c'est une chanson
très réussie, je pense là,
après coup, évidemment.
Mais c'est une chanson qui m'a
fait douter de... avant de
la sortir, comme j'ai rarement
douté sur une chanson,
parce que c'est un sujet
difficile à traiter.
Je savais pas si j'avais trouvé
l'équilibre entre... l'équilibre
entre la douleur et l'espoir,
encore une fois.
♪ Le ciel est back order ♪
Ça fait que non, ça m'a pas
traversé l'esprit de réussir
ou non à faire quelque chose
de mieux ou de moins bon.
- Benoit Pinette, alias
Tire le Coyote, merci beaucoup.
- Merci à toi.
♪ ♪